allez on en vient la situation politique
en espagne à présent avec un
gouvernement plus jeunes et davantage de
femmes au pouvoir le premier ministre
socialiste vient de remanier en
profondeur les représentants de son
exécutif
pedro sanchez veut redonner un nouveau
souffle à son mandat les précisions sur
place de clémentine laurent pedro
sanchez refait et rajeuni son équipe le
premier ministre espagnol a annoncé
qu'il allait remanier son gouvernement
au total ce sont sept ministres qui
quittent le bateau tout d'abord il ya
carmen calvo la première vice présidente
espagnole qui s'en va elle avait
notamment dû faire face à plusieurs
déconvenues politique face aux membres
du gouvernement de la gauche radicale
podemos le ministre de la justice s'en
va aussi juan carlos campos quitte le
gouvernement
et on se souviendra de lui comme le
ministre qui avait accordé les grâces
aux prisonniers politiques catalans
une décision qui n'a pas fait
l'unanimité ici en espagne
enfin du côté du ministère des affaires
étrangères il ya aussi du changement
mais cette fois les français peuvent
savoir de qui il s'agit puisque manuel
alvarez bono est actuellement
l'ambassadeur d'espagne en france et
c'est lui qui avait annoncé il ya
quelques jours que les touristes
français ne craignez rien en espagne
alors que la situation sanitaire
pourrait plutôt dire le contraire alors
ce remaniement c'est une surprise ici en
espagne
il était bien sûr prévu mais il est
beaucoup plus conséquent que ce à quoi
on s'attendait
ça votre côté le gouvernement est
largement rajeuni la moyenne d'âge tombe
à 50 ans et puis c'est un gouvernement
aussi très féminin en compte 14
ministres femmes pour neuf ministres
hommes
en somme c'est donc une équipe flambant
neuf pour nous donner un nouveau souffle
à pedro sanchez après la déconvenue
politique en mai dernier à madrid où la
gauche a perdu les élections régionales